hello everybody i am alex and i'm here
with Nick and we've been playing some no
man's sky lately and Nick you found
something kind of interesting when
you're playing earlier could you tell me
about it I did so during my first
playthrough in the first system I found
myself being attacked by space pirates
and I died pretty quickly and I decided
to go back a save in the options menu so
when I went back a save I realized that
my inventory was refueled with
everything that I had prior to being
killed but also my grave site was still
active in the system so the grave site
is that thing when you die you can go
back and collect all your inventory that
you had just lost right that is correct
so you would essentially duplicated your
inventory yep so basically when I came
back from the second save I had all the
same items and when I went to the grave
site it doubled those items so this is
just your ships inventory right that is
correct okay so I saw you doing this and
I realized that I have one of the most
valuable items in the game in my ship
inventory right now and so I thought
let's see if this works for me as well
so I went out got into a fight picked a
fight I couldn't win died reset my safe
to earlier and realize that my ship
still has the Atlas stone in it the
super valuable item that is both
important for monetary reasons because
it's worth sixty thousand pop and
important in the story and I realized
that both my ship had it and my grave
site had it so I went and picked it up
and duplicated my Elvis stone and then I
did it again and I did it again and my
ships inventory is now so full of Atlas
town until you can't refuel any of your
exosuit or any of the other stuff can
you do no more room yeah so is
completely like resource wise
irresponsible but I've got a talvez
stones now so I do want to make it clear
that this is definitely an exploit and
the developers at hello games definitely
did not intend for this to happen and
they'll probably patch it out with the
next update we want to be clear that if
you want to play the game with integrity
you know like it's meant to be played
then you probably shouldn't do this but
if you're looking to make bank and or
collect as many Atlas stones as you want
and this is a perfect way exactly for
more on no man's sky keep an eye on
gamespot com